hello everyone and welcome to the latest
edition of cfar talks today our
discussion will explore the topic of
future cities my name is Kate Getty and
I'm senior director of research at sear
as many of you know sear is a
canadian-based global research
organization that con convenes
extraordinary Minds to address the most
important questions facing sence and
Humanity at sear we believe in the power
of diverse interdisciplinary communities
of inquiry our researchers collaborate
on Bold ideas in order to share new and
foundational knowledge with the rest of
the world and that is precisely what our
cifar talk series is about today on
world cities day you'll hear diverse and
expert insights that will uncover what
it takes to shape thriving cities of the
future before I pass it over to our
moderator Katherine MC
I'd like to quickly let you know that
today's session will be an hour long
there will be a short Q&A period at the
end so if you have a question please
submit it through the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen and we will do
our best to address it lastly this
session is being recorded and will be
available on the cffr website next
week and now it is my pleasure to
welcome our moderator for today
Katherine
McIntyre Katherine is a reporter with
the logic where she covers environment
social and governance or ESG investing
The Innovation ecosystem and labor
issues in the Innovation economy prior
to joining the logic Katherine worked
for McLean's and Canadian Business
magazines in 2020 she won a best in
business award from the Canadian chapter
of the Society of American Business
editors and writers for her breaking
news coverage of sidewalk Labs she was
also named best new writer at the 2014
National magazine awards for her
investigation into cancer clusters in
New brunsw industrial towns welcome
Catherine over to
you thank you Kate and hi everyone I'm
thrilled to be moderating today's
seafire talks as a journalist I've
covered news on the Innovation economy
on Smart cities and environmental and
social governance issues um and all of
these are topics that play an important
role in how cities function today and
what they'll look like in the future um
so those are some of the lenses is
through which I view cities today as we
discuss future cities I'd like you all
to just think about the following
statistic in about 25 years 70% of
people in the world will live in a city
that's about 25% more people living in
urban centers than today I personally
live in a major city myself I live in
Toronto um and chances are I'll be here
in another 25 years and so I'm curious
to know what that will look like and
whether this city and other cities
around the world are ready for the
potentially seismic changes in
technology environment and migration
that are ahead so on that note um I'm
very pleased to introduce our speakers
um who will help us explore this topic
uh so first uh I'll introduce Kristoff
Brenner Kristoff is a sear as real
Global scholar in The Innovation equity
and the future of prosperity program
he's also an assistant professor at the
mlon business school in France welcome
Kristoff our second speaker today is gal
farady who is a Canada cire AI chair at
Mila and an assistant professor at
University de
monreal we are also joined today by John
love who is the founder and CEO of
kinget capital Canada's leading private
Equity Real Estate Investment firm um I
think John's also the only other non
seafire representative on screen today
Al with myself so great to have some
company there um and um we also hope to
oh Simon is here and last we have Simon
goldhill uh who's the co-director of
Sears Humanities Urban future program uh
Simon's also a professor at the
University of Cambridge and his work
focuses on Greek literature and culture
welcome
everyone um so to begin our discussion I
I just want to go back to that statistic
I mentioned earlier um it's expected
that by 2050 More than 70% of the
world's population will live in an urban
area so why are we expected to see this
this massive influx in a relatively
short period of time what are the main
factors driving people to cities um um
Simon can we start with you on that
question um certainly I think uh the
main factors turn out to be economic uh
that people think they'll get a better
life in the city that the way in which
agriculture is allowed to work these
days it's huge farms which make it
difficult for work to happen and I think
the resources of cities are dominant uh
across the world and I think that's
something that's extremely hard
us um Kristoff I can we get your
perspective on on that first question as
well yeah it doesn't differ dramatically
from Simon but I I think I have a a
slightly different emphasis on the
question so I I think you know the the
answer of urbanization is mostly um sort
of what drives urbanization is mostly in
emerging emerging countries where people
flock to cities for Economic Opportunity
so one of the questions that I'm asking
is why people stay in cities considering
that they are expensive and loud and
they can be overwhelming um and I was
thinking of um the famous urban planner
Ean isah Howard who wrote In the Garden
cities of tomorrow that they're like
these different magnets of country town
and Town Country so sort of the suburb
and of course there's a huge attraction
to leaving cities and to moving to
places where you know maybe your house
costs half and you can take a walk in
the forest but I think what attracts
people to cities and keeps them there is
the amenities um coffee shops and
museums and restaurants and community
centers for different ethnicities and so
on that afford um a great density of
social interactions um and they give
rise to to something that that um you
know I call you know think of as
relational comments so things that are
neither public nor private there sort of
some third Community owned thing um Jane
Jacobs talked about sort of the
sidewalks in front of her on on her
beloved Hudson Street as as an example
where um you know there is safety
numbers it's not just sidewalk doesn't
just get you from A to B but um but it
also provides safety to be in a sidewalk
with other people and soort of the same
benefits of density are true for
Innovation clusters that share talent
and ideas um and they can lead to
Technologies and jobs um and so I think
that you know these relational comments
are really specific to cities and there
are huge assets um that that make people
want to
stay just to follow up on that uh
Kristoff are there certain cities that
you look at around the world that you
think are achieving that well that are
doing that
effectively certainly um I I think there
are you know some that are incredibly
you know sort of thriving and um I think
this is a feature that like most cities
share in common honestly this is the
reason that we you know we like visit
the city or live in a city um I I
remember when I lived in Chicago um you
know going to hbal park on a Sunday
afternoon um and and sort of seeing
people dance salsa and PlayOn and you
know barbecue and run and swim and so on
it's like in these things you know sort
of the more people that participate in
it um the S of the better the experience
of going to the to the park gets um so I
I think um I think generally generally
this is a relatively Universal feature I
have some thoughts on sort of cities
sort of what divide cities that are good
at thinking about um you know their
future versus not um but we can you know
get back to this later sure yeah
um I I'll just throw a version of this
question to you John as well um what
factors do you think are critical to
equip a city for the kind of growth that
we're expecting to see over the next few
decades well uh firstly you know thank
you for having me um you know the answer
to your core question is follow the
jobs and you know if you go a hundred
years ago it took a significant portion
of the population
uh to be devoted to agriculture to feed
ourselves and today it's a minor
proportion so um hence we have great
cities um I think cities of the future
need to focus uh much more on
infrastructure being physical
infrastructure and most importantly
social infrastructure and um you know
growing fast growing cities uh and
Toronto is one of them have a deficit of
both um and you know social
infrastructure doesn't get enough
commentary in my view as physical
infrastructure does and neither of them
get enough attention and resources as
they
need when you're talking about social
infrastructure can you just give us a
couple examples of what you're referring
to there but there you know just to take
Dono as an example you know the the
classic school um structure is four
acres of land and and a two-story public
school but in in a high density City in
a growing densification city there
there's no more 4 acres of land for a
two-story school we have to rethink and
reinvent however we schools daycare
senior cares and all those other
elements of society today we have in
Toronto we've got apartment buildings
being built with a sign on the outside
saying there's no guarantee your child
can go to the local school well you know
that's just not Community Building
satisfactory or any other uh mention but
it's it's beyond that you know dayare
it's Senior Care places to worship
places to gather Parks um and you know
the whole element of social
infrastructure is what makes a great
City function and if you look at the
great high density cities of Europe they
do have turns out schools they have
places to worship they have Parks spread
around I mean you know these things are
in place and so it's where the newer
primarily you know North American cities
have to catch up in many
respects right yeah I I'm curious if
that's a function of just like the speed
of growth as well and that's a unique
challenge uh Simon you're you're shaking
your head there what do you have to say
on that what what comes to mind there
you're muted
Simon it's also a historical issue that
uh cities of that are most successful in
our general in quality of living as John
would call it uh are tend to be CS that
are
more they have layers of different past
ways and they've allowed those parks to
grow they've allowed those schools to be
understood over time and how they fit
into society the modern city tends to
have been LED when it's a very modern
city by economic uh demands that
restrict the use of space and it's done
so without due regard to social area so
I don't I don't think it speed so much
as a lack of attention a lack of care
yeah I might just challenge that a
little bit if I might you know I think
the regulatory framework work Trails
reality and so we find ourselves in a
system unable to uh adapt and evolve in
a high growth environment uh because I
can tell you from an economic
perspective uh you know we're very keen
on as as creators of housing we're very
keen on helping to create schools having
dayc carees we'd have many more dayc
carees if we were allowed to do so but
the regulations around what is a daycare
have to evolve to a high density
environment and these Reg ation are all
trailing what Toronto is
[Music]
today please go ahead I going to say
that it's also something to do with the
speed of planning the planning tends to
be rather a slow process and C move a
rather a fast process and so that's why
you're right cing about speed is that
cers usually outgrown their plan before
they've been built that's the
trouble and in's cas the good news is
it's a very high growth environment the
bad news is it's a high growth
environment and so you know all of these
things are I mean the problems we have
as a city are not because it's low
growth it's reverse it's because it's
high growth and and a and a lack of you
know prompt response to the changing
circumstances yeah um think we we'll
probably get back to to that and dig
into it a little bit more um but I I
want to go um to you g um I I we
probably all have a slightly different
vision of what our perfect City looks
like but I think you know uh most people
on this call um would probably agree
that a successful city is one that works
for everyone across socioeconomic
demographics and conditions um and G you
you uh recently co-authored a report um
for the UN on the role of AI in the
future of cities so talk to us a bit
about how we can ensure that cities are
inclusive and Equitable as they continue
to grow and as they're incorporating
things like AI into that that
development uh first of all thank you
for having me here I think my expert is
a bit different than the experted on
this call and um I think we can not
really think about the future of the
cities without thinking of like the
future technology and the impact of
technology and what I'm talking about
here is they are and that's kind of like
my expertise uh so the report that you
are mentioning was kind of like how we
can actually imagine like kind of like
you are hearing this words of a smart
cities right and a smart cities are kind
of like the terminology that people are
often using when they are considering
like how technology can actually going
to change the shape of the Cities right
but AI the one that we are kind of like
currently using and like you are hearing
from the news that the impact of AI is
going to be enormous indifference
application areas and like AI is going
to be actually used for different
sectors and these sectors are going to
be impacted on people's lives right so
when we are talking about the job
opportunities right we also need to
think about like how AI is actually
going to change this in terms of a label
Market in the cities because AI is going
to actually be replaced some of the job
that the currently is doing like people
are actually responsible for those of
course it can actually increase the
capacity for other jobs so if you're
look looking at like Co like during the
pandemic um like many people actually
changed the nature of the job from going
kind of like to their um office to kind
of like working remotely and actually
that changed the way that like people
are thinking about like their living
environment um people actually started
working full-time at home which was not
the case kind of before that it was kind
of like partially possible because of
the technology right so it can actually
change the nature of the jobs that we
are doing but going back to your
question of inclusivity I think this is
an interesting question to ask like how
AI system like if you are thinking about
in 25 years how AI system can be
inclusive because AI is going to be
impacting all of us and we need to be
kind of like making sure that it's
beneficial for everyone right and then
I'm talking about beneficial for
everyone we should also think about like
the harm right so going back to kind of
like job market right and I'm kind of
like saying that like AI is going to be
impact the job market the label um is
going to be impact some population more
than the others right and if we are
thinking about the inclusive way of like
adopting to this new technology we have
to consider and we have to kind of a
slow down even and thinking about like
the people who are kind of like their
job is going to change like what is
going to be accommodation for them right
some jobs kind of going to be better
because like people are thinking about
technology often The Narrative is just
like technology is going to be making
things more efficient right but it's not
efficiency that like is impacting
people's life right is efficiency some
sometimes uh kind of like translate to
people losing their job because like the
the system is going to be replacing
people right and Beyond this kind of
like job market and the impact of AI on
the job market it's just like the coin
kind of like they that AI systems are
developed is very much depends on the
infrastructure so when we are thinking
about like how cities are going to
change in the future and AI is going to
change that for the cities unfortunately
there is this difference of like the the
power and control of like infrastructure
around the world like who can actually
build this kind of big AI systems can
actually uh change the way that people
can use it and often like the solution
of AI is going to be kind of like
developed in um Global North and going
to be used in global South right and
this is part of of like the issue of
inclusivity because like the data is
going to be collected and part of like
the AI system is just this kind of like
power of data right and data is often
collected from Global n and if they
going to be using Global s they're
actually going to um create so many
issues you can think of like even the
simple loan approval the data is going
collected from uh Global North is going
to be based on the income level that is
very very different than from the global
South so the same system is not going to
work there and this is the mistake that
we are actually seeing like people
around the world in different cities
they are actually making because they
are just bringing the AI system just
because of a technology and impact of
technology to their cities without
really considering the value system that
they have the culture that they have the
data that they have the people the
impact of the people and also they are
not considering the infrastructure to
maintaining that right so we don't have
the capacity and it's not about like big
or small cities in this question it's
about like the capacity of like how much
we know about Ai and how we can actually
maintain it and it is the problem around
the world uh and I think like um the
question of inclusivity it's a very very
uh important question that we should ask
when we are considering AI
systems I can go on and go but I know
it's it's a complex topic and I there's
and my world especially AI is front and
center and everything we talk about and
I'm sure we could have a whole day
conference just talking on this topic um
um I want to go further you know rather
than going right into the future here go
take a step back for a second and go to
our historian on the panel and uh just
pick your your brain a little bit more
Simon on um lessons from the past um are
there things you know looking back on
what we've done right in city building
and where we might have gone wrong are
there lessons that we have learned or
things that we should have learned um
that might help us shape a better City
going
forward well the first thing I would say
picking up immediately on gan's remarks
is that technology is never understood
at the moment of its its
introduction and that's one of the great
problems of cities is that uh people
introduce technology without
understanding its unintended
consequences and I think that's
something we can all learn from and I
think that's a more General point and
the more General point is that planning
if you look at the city planning over
years has always failed that's to say
cities grow as I mentioned before faster
than their planning planning delay and
regulation is delayed behind reality and
you have to learn therefore to plan for
failure to plan for the failure of
planning and that's a really hard thing
to do because nobody wants to plan fail
they want their plan to be perfect to
look and really change the city but you
have to allow a good deal of really
sophisticated flexibility into your
system and one of the reasons why we've
leared over the past that we need that
sort of flexibility is that a city is an
extraordinarily complex unit there are
some very simple things about a city but
as a unit it's extremely complex and
trying to integrate its different parts
has proved extremely hard for planning
over the time which should make us very
cautious yes you can put a road in that
will make it faster to get from point A
to B which can be very good for for
economics but what will it be doing to
the social infrastructure that's
something that's quite hard to do and
putting in a place where you can
genuinely discuss and genuinely have
real Collective progress around the
consequences the Privileges and
priorities of planning it's extremely
hard to do politically and it'd be
fascinating to see if anybody has an
idea of how you can politically put
together what is always going to be
conflictual there's always going to be
conf in city and it's how you deal with
those conflicts that makes a good or a
bad City and I think it's fascinating
for us to learn what we found so hard to
learn and if that's not that's not too
paradoxical it's extraordinary that
human beings over hundreds of years that
we've lived in cities still haven't
worked out that exclusion is
self-defeating in the end that if you
don't have proper strategies of
inclusivity you end up with social
conflict that destroys the exclusion
that you originally wanted that's always
happened you should start from the
perspective of trying to be more
inclusive and trying to reduce conflict
we've also often forgotten how much
human beings need to personalize their
space to feel its personal that's true
for individual houses nobody wants wants
to live in a house that's exactly the
same as the next person's house but it's
also true of public space we have to
learn about how people want to use
public space won't always be the way
that politicians or other planners want
us to use public space and we have to
see that human beings are going to use
cities flexibly and we have to see that
as a resource of a city not a negativity
for a city and that's a really hard
thing for us to do and I think finally
what I would say is we can get some
lessons about
resilience that's to say that we are
facing a series of Crisis all over but
we should be able to look back and say
no cities aren't exactly the same but
can we get some lessons about how we can
be a bit more resilient one of them
might have something to do with
scale and it's interesting to think
about which cities people really like to
live in and think work there are very
few people I know I just may not know
them of course who go do you know what
the one place that seems to me really
got sorted is Mexico City or one place
that's really sorted is Ping you know
Beijing that once you get to a point of
a city of 23 million people and you know
massive scale it becomes much harder for
us to so that to me is one of the great
lessons we're going to have to learn
Aristotle said right back at the
beginning if you can't walk around a
city in a day it's not it's too big now
that's not going to be for us anymore
but we do need to think pretty hard
about what sort of scale we want and how
we're going to control that scale and I
think those are really really dominant
problems looking
forward right um Kristoff I see you
nodding there looks like in agreement
and I'd love to for you to jump in and
share your thoughts on that specifically
around you know planning for for failing
to plan and flexibility I really I
really like this idea of course that
that you know many strategy plans or
many plans you know sort of abound to
fail but you know I think that's not
inherently an issue because it's in a
nature of planning is you know you one
plane doesn't work out you make a new
one and and so I think that a lot of
cities have looked to this idea
infrastructure is when you put the plan
in place and things the
infrastructure
hard so so a lot of cities have have
looked to sort of more um you know other
forms of planning sort of strategizing
you know think about what are my
long-term Futures how can I define you
know key performance indicators how
we're going to get there and these tend
to be a little more fluid than sort of
you know our old school technical plans
so I I looked at some point at um just
to give you one example um city of
Copenhagen is now a little more than 10
years ago they said they want to be the
green and blue capital of the world and
you know it sounded a little utopian
back then and one of the things they
said is we want our our citizens to be
able to swim in the harbor and and you
now can in fact go and take a swim in
the harbor of Copenhagen and it's
equally clean as the oron strait so so
they you know they they got there and
now the city is pushing new boundaries
and they're trying to become alongside a
couple of others a carbon neutral City
so the net zero is a city and and so
these ideas I think are really
sophisticated and Powerful so I I was
curious you know how many cities in the
world um actually have a plan like this
you know where they think about the
sustain you know their sustainability in
sort of a strategic way and I I looked
at the 360 largest cities in the world
the a little more than a billion people
you know and sort little provocatively
it turns out that about 500 million
people in the world have a city
government that you know plans for
resilience and sustainability and there
are 600 million people in the world that
have no such city government right so
it's not just that the plans fail it's
that many many places don't have a
strategy for the future um and I you
know I think that's really a you know
you asked earlier about cities that are
doing it well and not so well I think
this is really a dividing feature is
that that some cities have you know
trained Chief sustainability officers
that work on these plans they're on
WhatsApp group together they try to
figure out how to deal with
sophisticated problems and and others
don't even have a chief sustainability
officer nor less one that's on a
WhatsApp
[Music]
group it'd be interesting to know how
Copenhagen managed to put together first
the idea and get agreement for the idea
and planning for the idea of course it's
a small City but do you have any sense
of how that actually worked because it
would be a bit harder to imagine La
doing the same thing right possibly
although La also has a chief
sustainability officer and they you know
they they also figure out a plan I um
anecdotes to share but um but but in any
case um you know I I think um this
requires a lot of really hardworking
experts that you know get together into
an office and like try to figure out how
to how to plan this stuff and um I I'm
I'm sometimes struck by the fact that
that a you know some of these some of
these people are responsible for it they
work in in sort of you know badly lit
officers in buildings that require
urgent renovation and they they you know
try to figure out budgets and plans for
bike lanes and for you know um uh you
know parks and whatever it takes in
order to make the city ready for the
future um and you know I have have
incredible respect for the people who do
this um this sort of strategizing
whether they you know the the strategies
end up being successful or not of course
is another
question yeah Kristoff just picking up
on that you know when it comes to Major
societal challenges like you you touched
on um environment sustainability here
but like are there any secrets to
effectively dealing with these issues
are just like good strategies or
approaches to dealing with them
um yeah I think there are um but I I
think that they're probably not what
most people think um I think it has you
know all respect for AI but I think it
has relatively little to do with picking
the right technology that one can
prescribe to one city you know I don't
know you know become smart build a seaw
wall add a couple of EV charging
stations or something like this um if
you take you know Green buildings that's
sort of a practice that 20 years ago was
much less common than it is now sort of
some sort of urban Innovation that's
intended to mitigate the causes adapt to
the effects of climate change um sort of
a a practice that's new to many
communities um and one that sort of I
studied in detail um you know you think
that these come from the government or
from Big corporate actors but in reality
it's often um nonprofit organizations
universities that acted as catalysts of
green construction so in the San
Francisco Bay Area the California
Academy of Sciences in Los Angeles the
national research defense Council in
many places little libraries that sort
of wanted to have um you know buildings
that are fit for the future um I can
think of Cincinnati as a good example
it's a sort of a success story where
there you know University of Cincinnati
the Cincinnati Zoo um a renewable energy
producer milink they like had really
early energy efficient buildings in 2006
and then um and then the city basically
passed that they call it a tax abatement
so this is like sort of tax incentive in
order to build more energy efficient
buildings and Cincinnati now has more
green buildings per capita than any
other city in the United States you
probably wouldn't have expected
Cincinnati of all places and and so I
think that sort of the secret sauce is a
mix of a proactive local government you
know people who think strategically
about what the challenges down the road
will be but who are also making the most
of the the Civic capacity of the city so
that the presence of pro-social
organizations that are trying to solve
social and environmental problems
actively so if you you for instance
compare Cleveland and Chicago Cleveland
has much lower Civic capacity you know
sort the community organizations
advocacy organizations they have about
half as many green buildings per capita
as Chicago does and so I I think if if
there is one single secret Source then
it would be or one were to act on this
the secret sauce it would be to sort of
make investments in a kind of social
infrastructure that John mentioned
earlier um and I you know I'm really on
board with with what you said before
about sort of this idea of supporting
organizations that can provide proofs of
Concepts that something can work that
other people hadn't thought of before um
and that's maybe less tangible Than
Physical infrastructure but I I think it
it works and it can explain sort of
Divergent paths that cities can
go so you know we sort of move from
cities to climate
change um and and you know I'll say to
affect the climate change agenda um you
know you got to mobilize Capital uh to
affect that outcome uh in Canada we've
got the Canadian infrastructure bank
which is making Capital available for
decarbonization projects um and so for
example our Royal York Hotel which is a
1350 room Hotel will be certified zeroc
carbon in two weeks it's been a 5e $65
million project it'll be the only hotel
in Canada zero carbon um and these you
know the Green Building Things are
typically what our industry does when
people go to a conference with each
other and they each give themselves a
Green Building award but nobody knows
what it what it really means but zero
carbon is something that we think will
resonate with our stakeholders um and
you know the federal CIB is making that
possible we've got another hundred
million doll of investments in our
office portfolio that are also going to
zero carbon um and none of which is
facility itated by the municipal
government because while they have
sustainability initiatives by themselves
what they consider a green building is
far behind what where we're going um
because we think their definition of a
green building is relatively not
impactful for our customers or our
assets but I mean to to the bigger
question of how do you impact leadership
it's it's about or how do you impact
change on any front it's about
leadership getting stakeholders align
around a common objective that people
can understand when you go to Copenhagen
and you say we want to be able to swim
in the ocean people can get what that
means uh and so people can act um and
you know what we find too often in
leadership domestically are are Niche
issues or issues that are not relevant
as versus you know swimming in the ocean
the blue agenda is a big a big idea and
they got and that's why it got done so
what what we need to do is to encourage
business business and government to uh
rally around bigger ideas that people
can understand and relate to and affect
all the stakeholders to do
that I think one of the most interesting
things that's just emerged in the
exchange between the last two speakers
is the potential tension between Federal
and Municipal Authority in taking cities
forward I think that's a really
complicated issue I think you know John
would be quite right that financially
Federal is going to is going to be very
important but in terms of the local
understanding of what makes a good city
will often be in Municipal interest and
how you put those together politically
can be a really interesting uh both very
positive when it does is is done well
but it's often done very badly with
people unwilling to share their
Authority you yeah Simon is is totally
correct and of course in Canada it's
worse um you know where you've got the
third level of government in the middle
sure right yes cities can can have ideas
but they're they're pretty hamstrung by
the province a lot of times in Canada
well I mean what we see in m in politics
here Municipal governments often say we
want to do this provided somebody else
funds it yeah and and and when that
funding doesn't happen the you know
Municipal politician says well it wasn't
my fault they wouldn't fund it so
everybody's off the
hook yeah um just sticking please go
ahead I just want to add one example
here that like sometimes technology
doesn't matter uh these kind of values
like kind of like uh is more important
so often you're hearing about the
autonomous cars right so you're not
hearing about autonomous um bosses right
transport system as a kind of public
transport system although the technology
is going to be the same the impact of
that technology is going to be very very
different so one is actually going to
positively impact the climate change
right so reduce the uh kind of like the
the pollution while the other one is
actually going to increase it because
more people are going going to use cars
because it's going to be autonomous cars
right the technology is going to be the
same here but like you are actually kind
of like the advertisements the value
that is going to be promoted the
economical growth of like one versus the
other is kind of like the matter that
kind of cities should actually choose
for themselves like which one they they
value more I think if anything we've
learned over the last say 30 years is
that technology creates an enormous
amount of we the challenge is that it
isn't distributed very evenly and that's
created significant problems and in
Canada you're finding it um really
focused on uh that you know the the
issue about housing costs which are uh
you know the whole housing crisis in
Canada is the product of two generations
of poor public policy and that have you
know either been designed uh by by uh
you know focused or by lack of attention
to lead us to where we are today in a
severe housing crisis which um is is I
think an existential problem for the
country because of its impact on
affordability and and technology and AI
is just going to create more wealth and
it's going to be just as equ just as
unequally distributed so it's going to
make the problem even
worse and of course you know my view is
the solution is not to uh make the
wealthy less wealthy it's to make the
less wealthy more wealthy right so how
do we make life more affordable and more
inclusive for more
people yeah um I just want to I we've
got a question from the audience here on
climate change so before we move off of
this topic completely I just want to
throw this to the panelists um they said
climate change is showing that the way
we approach in expand cities is obsolete
what could you say about the need for
cities to adapt to climate change
including Urban nature based Solutions
Community self-reliance in the aftermath
of extreme weather events public spaces
promoting mental health and City
decarbonization among others so we
touched on some of that but um there's
some new ideas raised in that question
there um if anyone anyone wants to take
a crack at that well I mean we're very
active in this space um and I think
decarbonization is a Core theme and and
a value Creator in commercial real
estate so what the city has done uh
which is to make deep water cooling
available to an Ever growing area of the
downtown which is effectively allows for
air heat exchange technology effectively
geothermal if you look at it that way um
which which is uh is no carbon uh and is
an enormous power source that should be
massively expanded um you know and and
to make a city function at all it can't
be sprawled you got to go up not out I
mean I think we would all well I assume
we would all agree with that um because
d it is the only way that you can make
Services readily available so to to
focus on climate change I think the
biggest focus is to is to you know
rethink the power source that is
powering most of the energy that's
consumed in the city which means moving
to electrical grid but it's also moving
Off the Grid entirely with regards to
things like the deep water cooling you
have here geothermal you have other uh
jurisdictions and and using uh
sustainable energy that way to replace a
lot of the energy
load yeah anything else add there
Kristoff yeah um you know I'm I think
there's a a clear link between this and
and what we were just discussing I'm I'm
as fascinated by the relationship
between National and municipal
government as the next social scientist
so what what Simon is Raising is a
really important question of course but
I think what's so interesting about this
case you know we can absolutely wait for
large large scale sweeping action to
deal with climate change from the
national level but while we're waiting
cities have shown to sort of you know be
able to experiment with different
solutions in pretty clever ways and they
come up with lots of new stuff and and
great ambition and I think one of the
things that stand out the most about
this is that they they often you know
cities often look towards each other in
order to figure out what's new so rather
than um you know maybe looking to the
federal government so I spoke to the
city manager of Palo Alto a while a
while back and he was saying that if if
they have a problem in Palo Alto you
know we're talking about climate change
it's like he he doesn't call DZ he
doesn't call Santa Clara County he
doesn't even call the mayor of San Jose
next door he picks up the phone and
calls the mayor of Barcelona because
these folks share the problems that they
have in paloalto which of course you
know Simon was talking about scale um
you know you know I have my questions
but in any case they see themselves as
being being part of a network of cities
um that has been facilitated by
organizations associations also by large
foundations like Bloomberg
philanthropies the Rockefeller
Foundation um the the urban
sustainability directors Network 100 RC
C40 e like a number of associations that
are trying to build these dense networks
where cities learn from each other about
what they might do about climate change
and how to become more resilient so I I
think that's um that's really uh
powerful way in which the municipal
level has sort of created its own um its
own space um of of ideas um the the
other thing I have to say about climate
change which of course you know is an
incredibly complex problem and we
already talked about the fact that many
cities do not in fact plan about climate
change at all uh and I quite behind on
this and is that often the most
interesting Innovations come from
outside the planner's office um and and
not from um you sort of from the
administrations themselves um and I
think that's that sort of shows how you
know simple Technologies um it it's not
really a matter of simple technologies
that are prescribed from the top top but
sort of stuff that you know comes up
from the bottom so here in Leon for
instance there is a little organization
called Leist um that is's a social
Enterprise they recycle food waste they
turn it into fertilizer and they want
you know they sell this to Farmers in
order to make some money and you know
speaking with them the the idealists and
many of them are volunteers and this
year the national government of France
has passed a law that large companies
cannot throw away their food waste
anymore you know their food anymore at
the end of the day but they have to find
ways of recycling it and suddenly this
little organization has the expertise to
actually show what it means to implement
the circular economy and they're at the
Forefront of trying to figure out how to
actually do this and so this this
expertise didn't emerge from inside the
city it actually came from you know from
these activists if you want and I think
that's a a really fascinating
fascinating way in which you know cities
can not only look towards each other but
also to what what leading organizations
inside are doing and I think the the key
um sort of uh you know capability that
cities have to build is to think about
how to identify these solutions that can
actually scale uh to to the entire city
you know what what uh maybe Barcelona
can learn from paloalto that works um
you know in all of
Barcelona it's very important to stress
that cities are the primary cause of
climate change as well as the place
where we need to solve the problem and
so sense that's a great example of the
way in which the local and the federal
have to interrelate I mean your example
of the French passing a central law that
everyone that's very good but it only
works because you've got that
possibility of local communities where
they can see the benefit lack of
pollution in your community is a much
more persuasive idea in sort of John's
term a big idea than it is to say
pollution across the world which is sort
of maybe a bigger problem but actually
you can see it in your River and your
street and so I think there's a really
important way in which local community
has to be part of this and has to be
worked through um can't do it alone but
it cities are going to be Central to the
solution in a way that I think federal
government has been slow to recognize in
many countries um and I think there were
many places in the world which would say
that it's the federal government has
actually been a block on the ability to
make the sort of Swift moves that are
necessary okay we've got a couple
questions from the audience here that I
don't want to neglect um there's one
here that's going to take us in a bit of
a different direction but uh I'm curious
what your thoughts are on it so um they
say what ask what are your thoughts on
including animal interests in City
Planning so there is a growing
literature on this issue in ethics
political Theory geography and urbanism
the idea is to take into account the
interests of domestic animals such as
dogs um feral cats um and uh wild
animals just squirrels and pigeons uh
and migrating birds any any any thoughts
on that I do have I have quite a strong
view on this which should taken in a
slightly different direction and that is
we cannot consider the questions of
climate change and sustainability
without considering food security and
food security is inevitably tied up with
the use of animals the more meat that is
eaten the more self-destructive we
become there are I mean it's just
absolutely and the figures on this are
so solid it is almost inconceivable that
people aren't acting more quickly and so
until we can actually move away from
some forms of factory farming with
animals and the effect on animals we're
not going to get to where we need to be
and it's one of the the sort of secrets
that for some reason doesn't get the
public airplan that it should get but
that for me is the absolute first and
starting point before we start thinking
about mice we should start thinking
about the interrelations of humans and
the production of food that said
um it's a very very tricky area I would
never use the language of Rights I think
that's a a distraction and a political
mistake what I would say is that in the
same way that a
is an integrated uh
infrastructural unit the part of that
infrastructure is the animal life and a
city where you have no animal life is
going to have real consequences for what
you want to do if you want to Green the
place you can't really have green
environment without any animal life it's
just not going to happen unless you like
plastic Greenery which is not what we
own mind so I see at that point you just
have to say it is inevitable to it will
come and it will come I think always
second on the agenda to humans still
because that's the nature of
self-interest and I think it has to come
third on the agenda after farming and
food security but I think it's a crucial
part of where we're
going
sure I I don't really have a universal
answer to this but than that you know
some cities are considering biodiversity
is an important feature of climate
change but just to underscore the
importance of that question um the the
mayor current mayor of Leon was like
voted into office on a platform trying
to dismantle the local Zoo which of
course now you know takes quite a while
and he might well be voted out of office
for trying to offer vegetarian meals in
in cens um you know which uh which is a
you know sort of for some a questionable
decision so you know the question of um
maybe not animal rights but at least of
um you know how we think about animals
in the context of food as well as um you
know the sort of as an amenity I think
is really a crucial question it moves
many so thanks for the
question um we have another question
from the audience here and um it I think
it might kind of relate to the question
of scale here so uh in any case they
they say our cities are becoming
Cosmopolitan in which most people do not
stay for long periods of time so it is
important to create cities with
different levels of benefits as in
infrastructure technology and resources
so uh they suggest one option would be
tall cities for cosmopolitan people in
one area median tall cities for basic
Services um health education Etc and
flat cities um which would be at most
three stories for uh with no
Cosmopolitan people uh and they're
saying thinking in the longterm about
100 years here uh would that be the
cities of the
future any any thoughts on that or
reactions to that that
scenario well I mean my my view would be
um the planning regiment um that exists
today in most cities is actually I think
uh too overwhelming for progress versus
the other way I mean the fact is that at
the end of the day people should have
choice on their where they want to live
which means that people like us that
that build and deliver housing have to
deliver more and different and
diversified housing types including
affordable housing so people can
effectively have those choices but I
don't think there's one size fits all um
you know the the uh when I was raising a
family I lived in a house today I live
in a in a apartment building um you know
it's different ages and stages but you
know people will make different choices
and I don't think we want to be thinking
that we're prescribing choices for
people I travel a lot but I've had the
same office for 38 years so I don't know
if that makes me C or
not um the uh I think what it's the one
thing is the heart of that question is
how we think about belonging in a city
and it's a really important question
about immigration it's a question about
temporary workers it's a question about
old families it goes in very very many
different different ways but crucially
it's about strategies of belonging and
how you can make people feel at home
when they arrive and uh feel at home
while they live there and that's a
really really complicated business and I
think it's again a place where we
haven't caught up with the world that we
are living with it's adaption and
evolution of social infrastructure yeah
that's what we actually need is more
adaption and evolution of the social
structure to recognize what we're going
to do so why is it you know is it
possible to go to a school for three
months because you're visiting and if so
how does that work you know why are we
putting bars on this or that form of
health care for people who come from
outside what are we doing with
citizenship I mean you can't be it's
very strange ethologically at least that
you can't be a citizen of a city you can
only be a citizen of a country and it'd
be interesting to know if we could think
about what belonging to Toronto rather
than to Canada would actually look like
but those are things that would need a
great deal of thought and a great deal
of work and um I'm not sure who's going
to do
it I just want to spend the last few
minutes here um asking going around and
asking you all about uh your Visions for
for the future um when you when you
envision you know the city of the future
a thriving kind of ideal city um what
does that look like to
you who would like to start with that
John go ahead well I mean it would be it
would be nice if physical
infrastructure uh would get ahead of its
requirement that ranges from uh you know
public transportation to private
transportation to everything underneath
the street uh much greater focus in how
to uh keep ahead of population growth
with um advancing uh infrastructure
secondly the whole concept of social
infrastructure um we we have to move
from a 1970s perspective to a 2040
perspective and and think about uh you
know what social infrastructure looks
like then
hospitals you know every kind of any
kind of medical care any kind of
Education places to worship uh you know
parks and so on um and and you know high
growth cities typically are far behind
where they need to be in physical and
social infrastructure and I'd love to
see a bold plan with some actual
action I think I would love to see the
infrastruct the the physical
infrastructure following the social
infrastructure rather than the other way
around if that's possible I'd like to
imagine how do we want to actually what
would be a livable environment for the
vast majority of people and how can we
create that I know we know how to make
very fast roads and I know there are
people who like to put very fast roads
through the middle of towns and say
hooray we have created a good physical
infrastructure but they're usually the
cost of the social
infrastructure and you know great cities
though have great public transportation
because if you if you can't move around
the city um in public transportation
you've got a real problem and cities
like Toronto basically has almost no
public transportation that's right no
it's crazy I mean the city has to move
it's like a shark it dies if it doesn't
move right but at the same time that
movement has to be a productive movement
it has to recognize also the need to
stop there's no point having a green
space if you get into it and stay there
you know and uh I suppose for some of us
the idea of an Italian Square a plaza
pataa when you can get through it on the
car but it's not going to go very fast
but you'll get through it efficiently
but there also people on the corners
having cafes private private private
transportation can never work in a high
density City love that that's
a but you have to but there needs to be
public trans transportation in a
highdensity city and you know I was a
few weeks ago in London and you know
that's that's a underground system that
works and is you know has got scale and
reach and why would you have a car you
wouldn't have a car it's much more
convenient um in Toronto we have one
subway line now I happen to work and
live on the subway line so I take the
subway but I'm one of the I'm one of the
I'm one of the privileged few that live
and work on a subway line and is a
travesty yeah I transportation is
another topic we could talk uh all day
about um but just in the interest of
time let's uh let's rapid fire go uh go
to you g with that last question what's
your what what's your ideal vision for a
city I think there's no for me there's
no future city I I hope we actually kind
of like celebrate diversity of like we
can have variations of definitions of a
city in the future as far as we do have
it in the kind of like currently and we
had it in the past kind of like the
celebration of this kind of what we have
and kind of like move from what we have
to the future is much better than just
kind of thinking like what is going to
be this kind of like futuristic city
that like everyone adopt to it and I
don't think that's kind of like going to
be for me the ideal
solution and you Kristoff your thoughts
I think um I have a strong sense of what
what a vision for cities is not which is
the line built through Saudi Arabia or
through the desert um and sort of like a
a tech enabled you know even even if the
public transit Works um I I think that
Ricardo roas who asked a question
earlier about different types of cities
got it exactly right and I agree that A
diversity of cities is crucial and I
think that um you know thinking about
about sort of an ecosystem of different
types of cities is the right way to go
and you know maybe slightly disagreeing
with Simon um I think that that the
current planners and people who are
running cities are not so far off in
what they're trying to do looking to S
different ways of making cities better
um but they're facing many small
problems that and sometimes big problems
that hopefully research can help address
better in the
future so um I think we've reached time
so maybe I'll jump in here to say thank
you all this has been a fascinating and
wide ranging discussion um Katherine
thank you for your excellent moderation
and I'd like to wholeheartedly thank our
panelist Kristof Broner gold nush farady
Simon goldhill and John love uh for
sharing your thoughts and expertise with
all of us today um to our audience I
welcome you to visit our website at c.ca
to find out more about this event series
uh you'll be able to view a recording of
this talk on our website where it will
be posted within a week um and I finally
would like to personally invite all of
you to register for our next event
called nurturing of resilient Earth this
special sear talk will play take place
on November 27th and we'll focus on how
Searchers are uncovering novel ways to
address the global um challenge of
climate change and we hope to see you
there full details about this event can
also be found at c.ca so uh thank you
again and I hope you all have a great
day